nous laissons toulon derrière nous pour
continuer notre parcours à l'entrée de
la rade de nombreux fort encore debout
illustre le système de défense mis en
place pendant des siècles pour protéger
la base navale
plus à l'est l'île de porquerolles et le
fort du petit langoustier un ancien fort
militaire qui date du xviie siècle
depuis deux ans il est entre les mains
d'un couple de passionnés bien décidé à
offrir une deuxième vie à l'îlot du
petit langoustier
en hiver la méditerranée prend parfois
des airs de bretagne
tous ces bons charité
mais il en faut plus pour arrêter édité
marque qui attendent ce moment depuis
plusieurs semaines il n'y a pas un
moment on en mer
soit là
car il voit enfin pouvoir continuer les
travaux de restauration de leur refuge
de pierre un fort militaire en ruines du
xviie siècle c'est une donnée importante
parce qu'en fait ce cas présent on a
fait beaucoup de restauration on a quand
même beaucoup beaucoup travaillé sur le
fond n'était pas très spectaculaire ça
ne se voit pas et là on va pouvoir
commencer enfin le vrai travail de
bâtisseur rebâtir
situé à seulement 100 mètres des côtes
de porquerolles ce fort est pourtant
très isolés l'îlot n'est accessible
qu'en bateau et par mauvais temps il
faut rester prudent balance lui mettons
à tribord
sage et des bouillons pas de pontons ni
de hockey c'est toujours une expédition
pour y accéder le département se fait à
même la plage
les deux marins ne sont pas les seuls à
avoir eu l'audace de vénus et surtout
super ses équipes l'on a aujourd'hui
parce que entre les cousins ceux qui
sont venus de marseille on pouvait se
dire que ce matin alors qu'il pleuvait
des cordes rendez vous à 10 heures ce
n'est pas gagné
ils sont là
gasquet tous
et notre champion
[Musique]
[Rires]
édité marques originaires de marseille
ont gagné un appel à candidatures pour
restauré ce fort ils en sont ainsi
devenus propriétaires pour 40 ans
avec l'aide de leurs amis ils comptent
bien le remettre sur pieds en respectant
l'âme du lieu
[Musique]
alors on peut composer et remplir un peu
comme c'était avant oui avec des plus
petites et des belles comme ça comme je
n'ai pas énormément d'accord on va aller
les chercher la corolla
on sait pas si ces six mois un an ou
deux ans c'est hier c'est la quitte en
train de bouger sa tombe et beaucoup
d'autres sont tombés c'est là vont
tomber et à ce moment-là tout s'effondre
donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on consolide
mais on consolide avec exactement les
méthodes d'autres fois
[Musique]
c'est bien mais on va prendre les
moyennes et des petites
ils veulent conserver au maximum les
matériaux d'origine ou alors ils
recyclent
les pierres locales le sable tombant des
murs qui s'offrit de l'eau de mer rien
ne se perd
du fabien là partout a dit à tamiser le
sable
amusé par
la tâche est complexe mais c'est
important pour eux de rendre hommage à
cette île de porquerolles un endroit
qu'ils aiment passionnément depuis
l'enfance
[Musique]
on a également un immense plaisir et un
grand de voir un grand devoir de rendre
ce qu'on nous a donnée effet pas facile
parce qu'il faut se battre tous les
jours pour y arriver contre la mer
contre trouver les les éléments pour
faire les travaux au milieu d'eux au
milieu de nulle part mais c'est au
milieu de nulle part rend les choses
encore plus belle et nous fait rêver
rêver rêver donc c'est le lieu pour nous
et magique on a beaucoup beaucoup de
chance beaucoup beaucoup de chance d'en
profiter
[Musique]
entre deux sessions de travaux édité
marque aime se ressourcer sur l'île de
porquerolles
surtout en hiver quand les estivants
sont partis
légalement c'est agréable à cette époque
de l'année nous sommes quasiment seul
s'est-il qu'ils aiment traversée n'a pas
succombé aux sirènes du bétonnage que
c'est beau c'est très loin de ça c'est
grâce aux performances
comme eux au siècle dernier
françois-joseph fournit un milliardaire
belge tombe sous le charme de ce bout de
terre et l'offre à sa femme en cadeau de
mariage
amoureux de la nature il veut en faire
un paradis végétal il re plante des
arbres des vignobles et importe des
essences rares
en 1972 une partie de l'île est vendu
par sa famille l etat qui crée alors un
parc national
une décision qui permet de protéger
l'île de l'urbanisation
aujourd'hui plus aucune construction
n'est autorisé à porquerolles
les chemins qu'empruntent édité marques
appartiennent à l'état un conservatoire
botanique a aussi été créée pour
protéger la flore originel a vu les
oliviers là ils sont bas on peut
récolter facilement l'avenir ils ont
récolté isolé ou aller voir certains
olivier son centenaire et bonjour
ça faisait longtemps
s'ils viennent aux choux directrice du
conservatoire
supervise la dernière cueillette de la
saison les vins
elle étudie la résistance des arbres
face au réchauffement climatique
une réalité sur l'île
la collection de référence
puisque
250 variétés
[Musique]
endroits
sensibles aux problèmes d'environnement
édité marques s'intéressent au travail
de sylvia qu'est ce que vous en faites
après on fait intéressant d'observer
ceux qui sont le plus adapté vous avez
dû changer un thématique six ans et on
verra quels sont les variétés qui vont
résister mieux au stress hydrique ou à
nouveaux ravageurs pour nouvelle maladie
qui arrive
en quelque sorte la banque de gènes pour
les générations futures pour qu'on
puisse on retrouvait remontée qui sera
peut-être la grande variété de 20
par rapport à des variétés qui se
retrouveront - date est à porquerolles
plus qu'ailleurs les ressources font de
plus en plus rares avec les derniers
épisodes de sécheresse l'été les
habitants sont souvent confrontés à une
pénurie d'eau tous ont conscience de la
fragilité de cet écosystème exceptionnel
pour ses cultures nicolas gayon
maraîchers de lille n'a qu'une idée en
tête
économiser l'eau en utilisant ces
bassins même l'hiver
[Musique]
les ces bassins sont alimentés eux mêmes
comment l'art
pour l'instant c'est l'eau qui vient du
continent qui vient par bateau le saint
christophe et parle par la récupération
d'eau de pluie directement dans le
bassin
ah oui d'accord
il est très grand six mille mètres cubes
je crains
amusant parce que nous le soir était
jeune ces bassins était désaffecté et
les jeunes de porquerolles mais elle
fait un terrain de tennis mais à
l'époque on plan on pourrait pomper dans
la presse c'est ça aussi des oreilles
nous avons ce bassin on ne s'occupe du
tout pompée dans la nappe phréatique non
il ya ce qu'on appelle un biseau salé
qui fait que l'eau et et saumâtre est
salée et impropres à la culture
maraîchère en fait les légumes puisque
à porquerolles les habitants
s'approvisionne uniquement grâce à ces
bassins l'eau est rationnée nicolas
irrigue au minimum et produits en
petites quantités
il était alors comment vous faites parce
que l'été qu'il n'y a pas d'eau 1 où
l'économie on fait tout pour
l'économiser notamment densifiant les
cultures ont réduit les espaces entre
les plans en effet d'économiser l'eau
partout où elle peut être économisés
notre objectif est pas de fournir
l'intégralité de l'ulm est d'avoir au
moins un point de vente de marché
produits sur place donc en vraiment
locales et d'approvisionner en cultures
vivrières warrants cultures maraîchères
une partie de la population de l'île et
des touristes qui viennent en été
porquerolles est donc une île fragile
mais le parc national qui en en grande
partie propriétaire veille avec des
règles strictes sans pour cela en faire
un lieu sous cloche
[Musique]
il est quand même très protégé alors
qu'il est si près du continent
c'est une île qui vit et qui cherche à
se protéger et ça je trouve ça
formidable don que les habitants font un
combat qui est tout à fait respectable
et dit sait de quoi elle parle la
passion pour cette île c'est une
histoire de famille
ses parents n'ont pas hésité à protéger
ce petit paradis des convoitises
immobilière
moi mes arrière grands parents déjà
venez sur l'île en bateau depuis pendant
très longtemps
mon père est là vraiment protéger ni
failli avoir un club méditerranée au
bout de la pointe des mèdes et mon père
avec toute une
avec les habitants de l'île et toute une
série de copains à lui se sont battus
pour la protéger pour éviter qu'elle
devienne un club trigano et vous allez
c'est une belle image de ville lousnak
mon agrandi qu'on arrangera des amis
qu'on est un mode de vie qu'ont eue les
familles et qu'on a fait du bateau et
c'est donc pour nous c'est un façon de
vivre aussi pour troll c'est pas
simplement lieu ''cela veut vivre celle
qu'on aime on sait marier ici à 46 ans à
la veille même
sur la plage
[Musique]
et à moi ça c'est incroyable voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais finalement pour ces amoureux de
porquerolles c'est peut-être de la mer
qu'ils préfèrent observer leur lit
[Musique]
voir les a virés
on a dû se prononcer
c'est pour le foie
voilà
pour la gérer
parfait
rions la mer est plate mais le vent est
fort voilà la petite risée
solution n'était avec ce même quand on
regarde les là on vient pas la plage y'a
que des bateaux que des bateaux que des
bateaux dès qu on est en dehors des mois
de juillet et des mois d'août c'est un
lieu absolument incroyable peu importe
le temps 25 noeuds de vent au milieu de
la méditerranée l'équipage se régale à
faire vivre ce bateau en bois
bord
d'un yacht à voile plus exactement
encore une folie d'éditer marque qui a
une longue histoire
ce bateau bad enfin le regina de 1871
celui là c'est une réplique à
l'identique fait exactement pareil et
empreintes il en existe plus aucun et il
nous fasciner un jour on s'est dit avec
marc bas ce serait pourquoi pas leur
faire des écriteaux lui qui l'a dit
parce que moi je me serais allé lancer
dans cette aventure pareille et nous si
vous intéresse à chaque fois c'est
d'essayer de concevoir en piochant nous
mêmes sur l'histoire en testant les bois
continuera réfléchir au vernis etc et
quand on fait ça c'est un plaisir
incroyable parce que du coup tu tout
autour de toi mais des gens
extraordinaires qui ont une passion pour
avancer
ah ça y est le fera paraît
[Musique]
ça a été toute une aventure pour réussir
cette prouesse navale mais ces
passionnés d'histoire et de patrimoine
n'ont jamais baissé les bras
elle obtient accouché dans la lumière
il espère maintenant réussir à relever
leur deuxième défi tout aussi bien en
respectant surtout leurs convictions
écologiques
l'idée de
chercher à faire une reconstruction qui
soit la plus simple possible avec
quasiment rien lisez c'est de réussir à
progressivement à rentrer dans un cercle
vertueux par rapport aux enjeux de la
planète fin de journée sur le chantier
après il ya la peur la file à éditer
marque se prépare à passer la nuit sur
le fort saint polois mais bon comme
c'est compliqué pour aller chercher les
choses sur le continent même sur sur
l'île de porquerolles on récupère tous
et le bois c'est c'est comme s'ils
étaient de l'ours question tout par un
temps comme en ce moment si on peut pas
se chauffer ses on peut pas rester sur
le fond ils ont consacré les premières
années à la construction d'un petit
refuge très spartiate pour se protéger
des éléments
nous répondre
en fait il n'y avait rien on était dans
le haut de la tour et il y avait il y
avait uniquement une pièce d'officiers
qui étaient là qui était déjà couverte
c'était était d'origine mais tout le
reste c'est nous qui l'avons fait pour
pour avoir une base vie qu'on puisse
commencer à travailler il ya tout qui
sèche parce que c'est être en paix et à
côté là on a un petit réchaud c'est très
très succinct ont narré chose de bateaux
c'est vraiment fait beaucoup bateau en
fait on a considéré cet endroit comme si
elle était sur un bateau en fait
alors des tomates des oignons
c'est un peu à la hussarde mais bon
à manger les trophées
est-ce que c'est mieux que de naviguer
mois en fait ce qui me ce qui me ce que
je préfère c'est moi j'adore naviguer
mais ce qui me fait peur c'est quand et
du grand en mer et ça j'aime pas mais
par contre ici peut y avoir une tempête
j'aurais jamais peur parce que on est
sur un vaisseau de pierre donc ça ne
disent pas et on compterait plus plus à
du mauvais temps et plus c'est beau
c'est le moment où je préfère le fond
c'est quand il et quand il est vraiment
assailli de tous côtés et là j'ai pas du
tout peur il est vraiment il fait il
fait corps avec le rocher complètement
et partie l'homme
m
j'ai voyagé de brest à venansault ceux
qui la rochelle jusqu'en avignon
[Musique]
les années passent et leur amour est
indéfectible pour cette île de
méditerranée
toujours prêt à la défendre
leur engagement est encore plus fort
depuis qu'ils ont trouvé ce petit refuge
de pierre au coeur des éléments
[Musique]
moi
dont je ne veux plus voyager
[Musique]
et wahaha
ça sert à rien d'aller plus loin
sur la côte varoise marin et passionnés
ont su se réapproprier l'histoire l'a
réinventé pour vivre aujourd'hui en
accord avec un monde qui ne cesse
d'évoluer
[Musique]